you have to celebrate Christmas right
it's not just enough to believe that the
child born of a virgin was the logos
from before the ages we can say we
believe that or we want to but if we
don't act on that information some way
and the way that you act on this
information Taylor talks about liturgy
and like let's say he talks about the
feast the act of Celebration as being
like a song right so the song has a
Melody think of like a little Melody has
qual moments you know all these
different notes and everything but
really the beginning to the end of that
song all happen in the same moment
because it's a unit so if you don't sing
the song you have no way of
participating in it in that moment the
moment just passes You by right and if
you don't celebrate Christmas then the
moment this holy moment right this
moment when Heaven and Earth everything
comes together into this point that
moment just passes You by and pretty
soon you stop believing at
all
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic
[Applause]
world so hello everyone I am back here
with Richard Roland for another episode
of universal history as all of you know
Richard and and I uh wrapped up a major
course on baywolf where Richard took us
to through very convincingly why baywolf
is a Christian poem and if you watch it
you'll see at the end I myself have a
like a mouthy gape like he just at the
end you there's no doubt it just like
all comes together it's very beautiful
so uh so you can still check that out by
the way if you're interested the uh the
course is going to stay on for sale on
the website so you can check that out
but today we are going to talk about
Christmas about kind of how Christmas
came together as a feast in the church
why it's so important you know why we
celebrate Christmas the way we do today
and so uh it's gonna be it's gonna be a
great episode thanks for coming on
Richard glad to be here um this is uh
one of my personal like hobby horses uh
is is defending Christmas I'm a I'm a
I'm a staunch uh veteran of the
Christmas Wars um for a little context
about this uh maybe some people remember
if you were if you were like a
fundamentalist Protestant especially
living in the South like the southern us
um I I like how Americans we say the
South as this is the only South but I
guess I guess people do that everywhere
but anyway um but if you were living in
the southern us you you might have been
familiar like you might have grown up in
like the worship Wars wars yeah uh so
the worship Wars was like the big kind
of like maybe you had this other places
too I just didn't grow up there where
you know was like do we do to like a
praise band or a piano in hymns or like
a piano in Oregon or you know there's
kind of debate about this kind of stuff
like my family was in the trenches of
all that stuff when I was a kid but then
uh as I grew up and eventually um you
know was on pastoral staff for several
years uh one day uh one day somebody
came to me very upset and said well
somebody's put up a Christmas tree in
the like the foer of the church and I
was like well I it's um it's December so
we we do that every year and uh it kind
of I was very I was uh totally uh
flabbergasted you could say like like
very caught off guard uh why would this
be a problem and uh but that kind of
that kind of uh initiated a multi-year I
don't say struggle but but uh a period
that I I sometimes kind of refer to my
wife and I refer to as the Christmas
Wars which had to do with which had to
do with uh some people um not all just
at that church but just like in our
lives Etc uh really really going hard
trying to get people to stop celebrating
Christmas and it's the usual sort of
stuff it's a it's a pagan holiday it's a
it's to Catholic etc etc and uh so that
is one of the things that caused me to
like really dig my heels in and start
studying um actually uh that was right
before I started working on uh what
eventually became a masters in
essentially medieval literature right
but it caused me to yeah like that was
one of the things that got me to start
like really dig my heels in and be like
all right well if this is really a Roman
Catholic thing then gosh darn it I'm
gonna understand why you know you know
as as opposed to just saying oh well
that's Catholic so toss that so it's
it's a weird it's a weird thing like
studying and sort of fighting for the
celebration of Christmas is actually
probably why I'm Orthodox interesting in
a weird way um that's like a part of my
story that I don't think I've I've ever
shared before publicly but but you know
that's one of the things that got me to
uh you know really think about what it
means to have tradition and what it
means to celebrate and there's a part of
there was a part of my conversion
experience that was certainly
intellectual right but the much more
important part was as we were converting
as a family especially for my wife was
the uh was the embodied part of it and
for us actually really deciding we need
to take not just Christmas but like
Advent seriously and and do these
certain things and then later on lent
and Easter like deciding that we needed
to to to find some way to make these
times kind of special as a family and
start participating this in a more
embodied way was a really important
turning point for our family it's
interesting I just want to say something
what you said it's interesting because
the this holiday war that we see it's
it's a strange place where secular
atheist types and fundamentalists hold
hands in their arguments and to be fair
not all fundamentalists um because the
again the family that I grew up in super
big yeah but like some fundamentalist
like really very particularly strain of
of fundamentalist like I know a lot of
people that were in that camp like anti
anti- Christmas Camp when I was younger
they ended up moving towards Jewish
holidays ultimately yeah that's one of
the things we'll talk about a little bit
later um and actually for people who
want to go back uh to last year's video
last year we did a a video it was a
sequel to the Groundhog Day video uh
where we looked at the the four winter
feasts of the the four Great Witter
Feast of the church and kind of talked
about how those are fulfillments of of
Hanukah or the Festival of the
rededication of the temple and the
rededication of the Temple of the cosmos
I'm not going to repeat myself on a lot
of that stuff today because people can
go back and watch that but so all this
to say uh this is this is like a a it's
a very you know passionate subject for
me so I'm excited to to talk about it
today so we're going to do this in two
parts I want to talk about a little bit
about how we got to have the kind of
Christmas C celebration that we have
today which is which is understanding
that everybody you know different
families do things a little bit
differently broadly speaking there are
certain things which if you live in
North America and you celebrate
Christmas there's certain things that
you're you're doing that you're you're
doing and you're doing them every year
and even if you're not doing them you
know some of them specifically they're
all around you they're in all of the
Christmas movies they're in all of the
like the the you know you can't get away
from it the grocery store the uh the the
the Home Improvement store the the mall
like all these things right you can't
there's certain things you can't get
away from so I want to kind of talk
about how we got to that Christmas yeah
and uh and then also look at some of the
historical attempts to abolish
Christmas and uh and what and then
basically the second half of the video
is talking about why that hasn't worked
why is stick is Christmas so sticky that
we can't seem to help ourselves when it
comes to celebrating it so that's where
we're going to go all right so I want to
begin with uh just talking about the
essence of the feast um this is you know
in some respects the most obvious part
and yet it's so it's it's weird because
it's so obvious like we constantly feel
like every year I mean you know six of
my neighbors right now have a have a put
you know keep Christ and Christmas kind
of a thing out in their yard with the
nativity scene and stuff and it's great
I love it um um you know I I really love
just all the statues of Jesus and Mary
everywhere this time of year you know it
uh it's great and
um um I really am serious about that we
we'll come to that in a a little bit um
but I think it is actually kind of this
beautiful return to tradition that you
see happening you know even in you know
the Deep South so yes it's a it's a
unconscious return to tradition you know
in very unsuspecting places and that has
to do with that stickiness that we're
going to talk about but but I just want
to start with like the fundamental
essence of the feast which I think will
help us understand why it is as sticky
as it is um and that it's it's the it's
the ultimate expression of the pattern
of the high becoming low right and and I
know this is a pattern you talk about a
lot people who are we were talking about
this the other day right people who are
like on this channel a lot or in the
various discussions around this part of
the internet think about this pattern a
lot but this is the ultimate expression
of this pattern right and it it what it
does is it manifests this pattern you
could say like more um evocatively than
almost anything else except for the
crucifixion yeah right right and so um I
just want to read something real quick
this is from you know uh uh this is from
our our
festal uh hymns for the feast in the
Orthodox church but the this actually
comes from uh this is just a setting
into verse of a mostly already metrical
homy or oration that that was given by
St Gregory the Theologian um on the on
the occasion of fop Nativity which as
I'm going to explain in a moment used to
be
celebrated on the same day so this it
says Christ is born glorify him Christ
comes from Heaven go to meet him Christ
is on Earth be exalted sing to the Lord
all the Earth and praise him in gladness
O people for he has been glorified to
the son begotten of the father before
all ages and incarnate of the Virgin
without seed in these latter days to
Christ Our God let us cry out you have
raised up our horn holy Are You O Lord
stem and flower of the root of Jesse you
have blossomed from the Virgin o Christ
from the mountain overshadowed by the
forest that's a it's an image from the
song of habak uh which the church
traditionally ascribes to the Virgin
Mary from the mountain overshadowed by
the forest you have come made flesh from
her who knew no man oh God not formed
from matter glory to your power O Lord I
Behold a strange most glorious mystery
Heaven the Cave the true Throne the
Virgin the manger a place where Christ
lay the uncontainable god whom we
magnify in song so this is like the the
really the the the key kind of the
center of our celebration and it comes
from a much longer oration that St
Gregory gave on this feast and he talks
about a lot of things that are I really
encourage people to go and read this you
can find it in his fesal orations um uh
the excerpt I was just reading there
comes from a book called the the the
winter PCA which is just a really great
kind of of a reader written by father
Thomas hopco back in the day on the
various feasts of the of the winter
season um and and each each chapter is
like maybe two or three pages and
there's 40 of them so um yeah it's a
it's just a really lovely little
reader but when he talks about a lot of
things he talks about actually how
should we celebrate the Feast don't
celebrate it like the pagans that is
with drunkenness we're going to talk
about drunkenness specifically today
because it comes up a lot as it happens
in talking about historical celebrations
of Christmas but not to celebrate it as
pagans but instead celebrate it soberly
as Christians uh by which of course St
Gregory means go to church feed the poor
right and and then you know yeah enjoy
yourself as well but don't uh you know
don't engage in the kind of Revel rates
the pagans engage in um um and there's a
lot of beautiful themes in this homy
right the high becoming the lowest thing
I mean there's nothing weaker or less uh
less powerful than aw Jewish baby in the
you know in the Roman Empire right you
know this you don't get any weaker any
poorer any less significant than that
right um uh the the one of the other
major images that we find in the ancient
hymns both in the East and in the west
is the um the uncontainable the idea of
the something that can't be contained
being contained right in the virgin in
the manger and so on and then of course
you know for us as Christians the the
Deep significance which you'll find many
of the church father is talking about of
Christ being laid in a food trough yeah
right as as you know like this is I mean
it's very very sort of evident
Eucharistic imagery right foreshadowing
foreshadowing that so um and also images
of like really images of the of the uh
Arc of the Covenant there in that that
text he wrote like between the cherubim
and everything like yes understanding
that there there's a relationship
between the glory of God
descending uh in the temple and Christ
being born out of the virgin
pretty yeah this is really important I
mean like the most common Orthodox Hy
about the theot toos is like the more
honorable than the Cherub them right
well to that to understand why that's
not just a nice thing that we say
because we like Mary right you really
have to look at hymns like this hym of
the feast right where we're saying right
the Virgin becomes the cherubic throne
right so like the the the cherim they
carry the throne well but she's the
throne right and that's why she's more
honorable than than them right because
she's the throne now and and she becomes
the throne in like the most like earthy
literal way possible yeah because J the
baby is sitting in her lap right this is
one of the earliest uh uh images that we
have of the Virgin from the catacombs in
Rome is this is the Adoration of the
Magi right um and uh which is the which
was originally by the way was originally
the focus of the Christmas celebration
in the west um we'll talk about we'll
talk about how how Christmas gets um
kind of split out from theophany and
Epiphany in just a second and then of
course one of the other major themes and
again I just suggest people go back and
watch that video we did last year one of
the major themes here is the idea of the
restoration of the Temple of the cosmos
right and it's it's sort of Link it's
ties to the Old Testament Feast of the
restoration or the Festival of Lights
what nowadays is called Hanukkah so um
so that being said let me talk about the
ancient Christian and medieval
celebrations of the feast so originally
Christmas and the or Christmas in
epiphany epiphany in the West theophany
in the East they have different emphases
but they're the same feast and I'm just
going to probably call it theophany the
rest of our conversation but I'm really
including both I mean the the the
differentiation of emphasis is very
ancient um as you know so theophany
focuses mainly on the baptism of Christ
Epiphany focuses mainly on the Adoration
of the Magi yeah there was also like a I
think that the idea of the early Feast
was something like the Feast of of the
revelation of light that's right that's
right I mean that's the earliest that's
the earliest thing like it's the Feast
of light right the festival of light and
of course when St Gregory is is is is
delivering that Festival oration that's
the occasion on which he's doing it yeah
which is why like there's all while all
those images come together right the
moment when Christ is first recognized
in the world so the Magi the the the the
baptism but then also like the wedding
of Kaa for example would be mentioned in
those early feast and so like all these
moments before Christ reveals fully the
glimmer of light appearing in in in the
Incarnation really like everything
culminating up to the baptism right that
that whole kind of episode which is
where two of the gospels start right two
of the gospels just began at the
baptism um which is which is an
important detail so yeah so originally
this is all kind of one feast and
actually in Armenian Christianity is
still celebrated this way right all on
one single feast
what happens beginning in the mid fourth
century is that uh the the celebration
of Christmas gets to sort of split out
from n from Epiphany theophany into two
feasts uh which are 12 days apart and
the reason for this is basically
arianism so arianism is the uh it's the
sort of you know the arch heresy as far
as Christians are concerned right it's
this teaching that the son was a
creature that he was not eternally
begotten um it's does not necessarily
the teaching that uh Jesus wasn't God or
Jesus wasn't Divine which is how some
people will try to explain it sometimes
because Aries actually did believe Jesus
was divine he just believed he was like
a Divine created thing like a like God
or something like like like right a God
right and it and of course this creates
poly you know polytheism and various
other problems for Christian theology um
one of the permutations of
aryanism is uh something called called
apollinarianism which is basically this
idea that um and there there are a few
different versions of this right but
it's basically the idea that Jesus was
just like a normal good person and then
at some point and most people who
believe this set at the baptism that the
lhost comes in and fills him right yeah
we call adoptionism sometimes yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and and a lot of these
things I mean there was like adoptionism
and then arianism and then
apollinarianism and a lot but I mean a
lot of these things like intersect so
much it's not totally important for our
purpos today to like G out the
individual most important to say that
what was what became important for the
Christians was to say that incarnate
logos was incarnate from the moment of
conception and not at not at some later
point during the story so that's exactly
how this becomes you know if you go back
and and look at those those hymns that I
just read right there's this talking
about how the whole focus is on how
Christ that is born in the manger that
is being adored by the m right is
already God before the ages worthy of
our adoration right and in this context
the gifts of the Magi which is the big
focus of epiphany in the West becomes uh
emblematic becomes the emblematic uh uh
act of worship right this this of for
the total giving of ourselves right
where we have nothing to give to Christ
but ourselves and I'll just say on this
note there's a really wonderful series
of like Prince I think they were done as
originally as like postcards by an AR
Nuvo artist name um I think it's edio
anini and I probably got his name wrong
but he was an Italian artist he did a
series of like sort of postcard prints
of like the various titles of the Virgin
but one of them for the M Christi uh the
mother of Christ he did the uh he does
the Adoration of the Magi and it's one
of my favorite images of the Adoration
of the Magi because one of the things
they have them doing is taking the the
incense you know so you got the three
gifts gold frankincense and myrrh right
well so taking the
frankincense and burning it in a sensor
before the Christ child and I don't know
why I never thought about that before I
saw that image but of course I mean if
you believe this is this is God before
the you what do you do you what do you
do when you come to a god or even like
an emperor for that matter right you
burn incense right it's an act of
worship an act of veneration and so um
uh it's anyway it's a really beautiful
image and very evocative in that sense
right so this is the big focus of
Christmas right by celebrating it we're
going to talk at the end of the video
today about the importance of
celebrating something why it's actually
not enough to just think something
correct but you actually have to
celebrate it you have to embody it in
some way right which by the way is
something that that everybody knows yeah
right even even the sort of like the the
the the anti- culture right knows this
right and that's why you have to have
pride month and that's why you have to
have celebrations you need not it's not
just remove celebrations you have to
replace with something that right
exactly yeah so what happens pretty
quickly is uh is that uh we start
preparing for this great feast um with a
period of preparation and so in the west
this used to begin back on November the
11th um and in the east on November the
15th either way it's sort of a 40-day
fast um in the west it was called St
Martin's lent because it originated in
the dases of Tours in France um so um if
you came to the bolf class you will know
I made a lot of jokes at the expense of
the French but today I have only good
things to say about the French so so uh
yeah well it is Christmas Jonathan it is
Christmas that's
right yeah um I'm gonna have good things
to say about Martin Luther as well so
there you go yeah so um so if you go
back and look at the sixth Century
councils in the west starting in France
uh the the Council of Tours and then
kind of spreading around there it
establishes Advent and Christmas tide as
separate seasons and it seems like this
was because uh people had started to
like pre-celebrate a little too much
right uh which is the thing we do in our
culture now we're like well Christmas is
on the 25th and we got to get all the
Christmas parties the work Christmas
party and the gym Christmas part all in
before Christmas you get all in before
Christmas right well this is apparently
a very old problem and so uh and so what
they did is they established they
established these fasts as a way of
making sure we're preparing properly and
then also establish Christmas tide the
time from Christmas to Epiphany or
theophany as being as being a time of
feasting right and so this is kind of
how it takes the the general shape that
it does so for instance the current
Advent season on in the west which
doesn't start on November the 11th it
starts on December the 1st uh or like
the first Sunday around there uh that
that dates back to the late 6th century
when uh monks were required to fast for
the first 24 days of December and it
seems like this was because they had
been breaking into the Christmas Ale a
little bit early that's right yeah they
had their Advent calendar now that just
has chocolate in it like people eat
chocolate every I like the ones that
have just like a little thing of a
different Scotch whiskey in each of the
doors there you go that's unfortunately
I can't participate in these but uh but
I think it's a neat idea so
um but uh so there's a basic rule of
thumb for understanding why different
cultures have different Christmas
traditions and that is the colder your
winter is uh the bigger deal Christmas
is in your culture right and that's
that's more or less true across the
board there's some exceptions to it uh
but but put it another way the colder
your winter is the more Christmas
customs and traditions your culture will
develop and like the stickier those
things will be yeah and um because it's
darker too right you have that sense of
this dark moment when the into which
Christ is born and i' by the way uh I've
heard some people say something like
sometimes well the Orthodox are really
good at celebrating Pasa they just don't
know how to celebrate Christmas or
something like this but like go go to
Ukraine go to Russia go to any of those
like northern European countries where
it gets very cold very dark right uh go
to even like Serbia and and the Balkans
you'll find all kinds of amazing
Christmas carols Christmas traditions
stuff you've never heard of stuff that's
really similar to stuff you grew up with
um so it really has a lot to do with the
weather and particularly like you said
the amount of Darkness that you have and
uh I'll say a little bit here about the
connections between um and we said a lot
more about this in our last video so
again go back and watch that people and
in the Groundhog Day video as well but
the connections
between the connections between like
Pagan Solstice celebrations and this is
a thing that everybody has a winter
festival absolutely if you have a winter
you have a winter festival and I realize
I'm talking kind of mainly about the
Northern Hemisphere right now um I don't
know what to do about that but um you
know we can yeah it's sorry people in
Australia like I don't I don't know what
to say but or in South Africa South
Africa or yeah yeah yeah right right um
but uh basically like as the as the
light Recs right you get to the deepest
darkest part of the year and everybody
has this deep um cultural it's sort of
deeper than cultural actually like this
really primitive uh sense that a
festival is needed that light is needed
right and um we have to light a bonfire
we have to light we have to light the
fire it's just inevitable to think that
way yeah we have to find the light at
least we have to like get some hope for
for the sun to come back and this seems
to be the main reason for people
rejecting the idea that Chris that
Christ might have actually been born on
December the 25th because it makes so
much sense because it makes too much
sense like that's too perfect that goes
together too well right
um I would just say you know uh you know
who made the agricultural cycle who made
the seasons right right and and uh so so
for me it's it's just this is when light
would come into the world when else
would it have happened right when else
would it have happened and um so a lot
of uh so all this to say if somebody
says to me um such and such Christmas
tradition you know like the Christmas
ham or something like this that goes
back to this old Germanic Pagan custom
at Ule or something like like
this okay all right are you coming over
for dinner or what like you know let's
you know um yeah that's that and and
really that should not be a problem for
us if you understand the way that these
things work right um and uh so a lot of
the
Traditions that we associate with
Christmas had already started developing
by the late Middle Ages um uh uh one of
my favorites here is car
right uh and and here I have to say
something which may upset some people um
but I don't mean to all right and that
is that a Carol is not the same thing as
a him yeah nowadays in like Modern
English Parliament when somebody says A
Christmas Carol they just mean a a
religious song that you sing at
Christmas time right or a semi-religious
song that you sing at Christmas time
it's just like a Christmas song that's
what we mean by Christmas Carol but
carols are not the same things as uh as
hns and in fact carols were not sung in
church until about the later half of the
19th century really yeah not sung and
and carols were not to be sung in church
yeah yeah they're not they're not
lurgical at all they're not lurgical and
uh uh you've got to sort of think about
so actually sometimes you'll find
medieval Bishops writing against the
practice of carolling this is a little
funny to think about because I know that
you know some traditions really love
their like lessons in carols service on
Christmas Eve which I think is awesome
quite frankly and I'm not going to stop
you know I'm not telling anybody stop
doing that but it's quite funny to
realize that there are lots of medieval
Bishops you know in France and England
and other places writing against the
practice of caroling well why are they
writing against the practice of Caroline
because Caroline is um uh it's a it's a
sort of a it's a carnival practice right
you're going around from house to house
and you're usually going with a keg or
like a large bowl of very alcoholic
punch and you come up to the door of the
place and you sing and then you offer
the people at the house you offer them a
drink in exchange for like a gift gift
of some kind right and this is this is
caroling and um which by the way sounds
like a great time uh we we tried to do
caroling uh every year just around our
neighborhood and um and uh but I've
never like been like have a sit from the
flask as well neighbor like maybe I need
to bring that in but um that would
definitely make you more popular if you
yeah yeah yeah or less popular depending
on which neighbor depending on which
yeah but but anyway my point is that
that that all of that sounds awesome
okay but this actually helps explain the
kind of the character of Christmas
carols like if you go back and look at
some really old medieval Christmas
carols especially like medieval English
carols which is what most of us know um
sometimes they're uh they're let's put
it this way they're not usually
theologically explicit yeah um there A
lot of times they'll have be be
something like I Saw Three Ships on
Christmas day or something like this and
there's a lot of metaphor and it's the
way to think of it is a sort of a a
lyrical Veil over the mystery
yeah and why is the mystery veiled in
this way well it's
because it's because we're not in church
right and we're going around town and
we're slightly drunk at this point and
also some of the things that they sang
along with Christmas carols in the same
setting were drinking
songs yeah
um how much trouble how much trouble am
I allowed to get into much trouble as
you okay so I'll just say that there is
a um uh there's a collection like a 15th
century manuscript that collects a bunch
of Christmas carols including one of my
favorite uh medieval carols which is
called Adam Le I bounden we'll talk
about that in a second um but it also
has like songs
about somebody's male
member um um the lyrics of which are are
quite hilarious actually and and the
thing you have to understand is they're
going from house to house and you're
getting songs about like the fall and
original sin and and baby Jesus is a
manger and then also here's a here's a
funny you know body humor dirty like
yeah like yeah here's a dirty song right
that that's that's how carols were used
that's what caroling is um this is this
is the uh those are the only two
registers anybody has in the Middle Ages
you're either like contemplating the
mystery or it's body humor and those are
the two like there's nothing in between
when would they Carol like when what dat
what days do you know well so the the
the thing that the really try to enforce
is caroling doesn't start till Christmas
night after Yeah Christmas night and
then um and then you you go you go
around caroling after that and of course
eventually uh what happens is that um
the distinction between Advent and
Christmas tide gets kind of lost and
that's how we get the situation that we
have today but that doesn't really
happen until the 19th century yeah um
and then of course this culminates
eventually Carol's become a Nostalgia
thing um at least the ones that aren't
about you know humor uh yeah uh forget
about those don't know them now they
become they become the wedes you here at
the mall and by the way there were
carols I'll just say there were carols
for other holidays too yeah okay um some
very famous very famous like Ash
Wednesday carols okay um uh uh Good
Friday carols U even one uh Carol for
the circumcision of the Lord that I that
I managed to find so there there were
like historically there were other
carols as well but Christmas was like
the main time you went caroling and it
has to do with this it has to do with
this you the winter of it all basically
right you need a drink it's like yeah
you need a drink cold and it's dark
drink yeah yeah um so um we also get
things like the Christmas boar um
there's there's actually a famous Carol
about this the boore is head at
Christmas which is which I really love
um the use of especially in Western
Europe the use of everg greenery you
know like Garland Holly um um Evergreens
you know fur trees things like this they
used have this to sort of like uh sparse
up the inside side of the house right
with like lights and Evergreen which is
if there's any aesthetic which which is
like identifiably Christmas it would be
lots of lights and just Evergreen things
everywhere right um and again when most
of the world is dead except for these
particular plants yeah right that it's
very easy to see why why that would be
done and and also winter berries like
the idea of a winter Berry is really
important with Christmas because it has
that light or that seed that's being
preserved and you can still identify it
even though everything else is dead yeah
now that's uh that's a beautiful way to
say that and uh even things like
mistletoe which we we know like as
modern people we know it to be a
parasitic fungi right uh but fungus but
but for medieval people the mistletoe
had all these other connotations right
you know the the um but also like it's a
little poisonous so it's yeah but uh
it's it's it's one of those interesting
things go look at the way that mistleto
is used in medieval symbolism that's a
that's the whole video I think but
really um uh so you have uh you have all
this stuff that comes in uh another very
important element that should not be
overlooked is the feasting of the poor
so this is a really important part of
actually any Christian celebration um if
you if you want to be tra and you want
to go celebrate holidays in traditional
ways if you're not buying a meal for
somebody else right or or you know get a
case of beer for the guy in the corner
or something you know like if you're not
if you are not actually feasting the
poor in some way then you aren't
actually tradition celebrating
traditionally and so the way that it
worked in for instance in medieval
England is that there were certain days
of the year uh Easter St John's night
which is the summer solstice and then
and Christmas uh specifically other days
as well but those three days
specifically when it was expected that
the welltoo members of The Village or of
the town would put out a feast for all
of the poor people right and it's sort
of like come and get as much as you want
of all the richest Foods right and this
is a really important part of the
celebration as well um and a lot of
times when we talk we think about like
the social inversion aspect of some of
these holidays like like the boy Bishop
feast or the the Feast of the ass on
January the 14th right obviously the
there's there they have a connotation of
like misrule and things like this and
those aspects were always always a
concern for for religious leaders
especially those of the more sort of
uptight variety um but also an a part of
the the whole idea of inversion is that
poor people get to eat what the rich
people have and that's actually a really
important Dynamic within Christianity
and a really important Dynamic within
the traditional observance of these
feasts yeah and that's still like today
we still have you know the kind of
Christmas uh I don't know how you say it
in English but you know like to gather
around food for Christmas like you go to
you for for poor people and make boxes
for families that struggle and stuff
like that's definitely still even in a
secular world it's a
there I I think every church that I've
ever gone to as a member uh both as a
Protestant now as an Orthodox Christian
has done that for Christmas and um even
the grocery stores get in on it you know
it was like here's a bunch of
conveniently packed bags of food you can
just buy one and we'll donate it to the
shelter and and things like that so um
you know uh the rule about charity there
are two rules about charity uh no since
nobody asked there are two rules about
charity one is that the the the less uh
the closer the proximity the better
right um the more
times my money changes hands I'm not
even talking about like where's that
money actually going because this
doesn't actually seem to be a question
that we're supposed to ask as Christians
I mean be a little Discerning about the
Charities you donate to but Christ you
know Christ says to give to every man
that asks of you right so not but what
is he going to do with it later um but
but anyway the more times that that gift
changes hands right basically the
farther away I have to be from my
neighbor to give to him right the let's
say like the less salvific it is right
it has a different effect on your soul
if you are personally you know giving
something to somebody you're looking
somebody in the eye you're seeing them
as a human being right it's that's a
very different thing than I just I just
gave some money to a to a charity online
and now I'm covered and I'm not saying
don't give money to Charities online
like do what you can't do what do what
you can do but but but maybe don't um
don't underestimate the importance of um
and this is just the real difference you
could say like between religious charity
and uh something like government welfare
right um is that there is a sort of a a
depersonalization that goes on right
that makes it um you know never mind
what the effect might be on the person
who's on the receiving end right but for
the person um you know um St John
christum lots of lots of famous homilies
against you know wealth uh there there
are no warnings to the poor in the Bible
you know and um but one of the things
that he he you know to paraphrase you
know said you know what are you saving
up for hell you know kind of you know
that kind of an idea but um yeah but he
talks a lot about this and and says you
know the poor man is there for your
salvation right you know so you can't
neglect him right so this is a really
important part of of the celebration of
this kind of feast and uh it's also a
very important part of understanding the
symbolism of Christmas right the highest
thing becoming the lowest thing right
that
inversion uh which is which is at the
heart of charitable giving Works of
Mercy but is also at the heart of the
the parts of the feast that make certain
people
itchy right the the the the inversion
the like the social inversions and the
and the the the rry and things like this
that all of that is actually part of
that that symbolism of the highest thing
becoming
low so um uh and then of course you know
this inversion can take darker aspects
right drunkenness gambling Etc um that's
always been a problem PE and and and you
know like uh people in charge have
always tried to sort of figure
complained about it Christmas yeah for
sure right always got to figure out how
to manage it right and I just want to
reiterate a lot of the things that we're
talking about here you know you can go
back and look at like saturnalia as this
time of inversion or or something like
that um a lot of things we're talking
about here can just right I think should
be rightly understood as Integrations of
pagan sols to celebrations and should be
fine right if we understand the way that
Christianity works the way that Christ
works the significance of his coming
into the world in the Deep of winter
this should not actually present us with
the difficulty yeah I mean I mean think
about it like it's weird because also
think about in the Middle Ages the
bishop complaining that you know people
in the town got too drunk instead of
mentioning how they were massive orgies
you know like right yeah like the Saturn
Everything's Relative that's right
Everything's Relative so you can
actually see how how Christianity
transforms these types of Feasts to like
to be able to give some room for a bit
of messiness to like point it but then
point it towards towards a better path
you could say yeah um uh I'm gonna talk
a lot about Charles Taylor in a second
his a secular age but he talks about
these times of Carnival as being like um
the idea of like if you have wine and a
wine like wine aging in a wine skin and
you don't like unstop it every once in a
while eventually it's going to explode
right the gas is just going to build up
and it's going to explode um it's the
same kind of a thing here like you do
have to have a little bit like like you
shouldn't get drunk but then also there
are times when people need to get drunk
right those are like the two weird uh
that's the weird dichotomy that you find
even in scripture even in scripture you
find this right you know that there are
in Leviticus right you know there's a
whole like and if you can't go to the
Jerusalem for this particular Feast then
take the money that you would have spent
on the trip and uh throw a big party for
your friends and eat and be married and
get drunk before the Lord right you know
and so so it's it's it's a weird it's a
weird kind of a thing and I think I
think that the the balance the church
has traditionally struck is that you
always have uh you always have people
saying knock it off you guys and you
always have people sort of doing it
anyway and that seems to like that seems
to like hit like a good kind of
flexibility and this is really actually
with this point is such a great point
that you're making and it's one that
that uh it's that people don't
understand traditional societies work
because we tend to or understand
Authority as always as absolute
Authority that has absolute reach and so
when we know that like you can't cross a
red light we know that if you cross a
red light then you'll get a ticket you
know they'll they'll take a picture of
your license plate and then you'll get a
ticket by the mail or whatever and so
but in a in a traditional world like you
said it's actually a it's actually a
dance right there's a dance like you
said between different faction that
create this kind of balance that move
that doesn't always remain the same it
kind of moves sometimes maybe it'll be
moments where it's a bit more
puritanical sometimes we will be a
little more permissive and then it'll
kind of slide back and forth between
that but that's the dance between
exactly that that the balance is saying
yeah knock it off but then doing it to
some extent anyways yeah the the kind of
people you always want to be careful of
are the either like the Puritans or like
the total hedonists right that's right
either one of those extremes is a really
dangerous person it's a dangerous person
to have in charge of your church it's a
dangerous person to have in your life
it's a dangerous kind of a person to be
that's right um so this is the danger of
going and and like just reading a whole
bunch of canon law and then looking
around at the people in your Parish or
your
priest nobody's doing what's there what
a bunch of terrible Hypocrites none of
them are doing what's there because
that's not it's not really how that
works right and uh but the thing that I
wanted to point out is that the the the
the when you talk about hierarchy right
the bishop that the church has canonized
that we set up as being this is the kind
of person that you should be because
they're like Christ so you should be
like them if you go and look at the
lives of of the Bishops the churches
canonized one of the things that's
basically Universal among them is their
care for the poor right that they were
out setting out a feast um out of their
personal treasury not just
for uh the poor on certain feast days of
the year but every single day right so
they're the people who who best embody
the the highest thing you know in this
case the bishop right the highest thing
becoming the lowest right um and their
ability to kind of do that and um and
so it's it's this sort of it's this sort
of interesting I mean the other big
secret that that is kind of offensive to
Modern Christianity is that uh I said I
said a minute ago like there are no
wordings to the poor in in the
scriptures yeah and and if you look at
the way that this has been that this has
been
uh the the rigidity and the flexibility
that we're just talking about the way
that's been enforced is it's the idea
that the poor man is the man who needs
the party and maybe he needs to get a
little drunk right and then but it's
actually it's you know it's the it's the
well-to-do person you know feasting with
all his friends he's the person who
needs to be uh uh who needs to be sober
and celebrate more soberly right and one
of the weird things that happens in um
this is this is what Taylor calls like
multile multiple speed Christianity
right um and one of the weird things
that happens especially with puritanism
is this idea that no there's actually
only one speed and we have to hold the
poor person to the same standard that we
hold the rich man um and that sounds
really egalitarian now but it's um not
actually that's not actually how
traditional societies work so okay so um
kind of one of the things that I want to
point out that is maybe a little
different in the medieval celebration of
Christmas both in the East and the West
um is the Focus um uh especially on
Christmas Eve in specific the focus on
Christmas Eve uh uh on the the retelling
of the story of Adam and Eve so if you
go to church on Christmas Eve uh in the
Orthodox Church uh you'll
hear the the reading of the opening
Narrative of Genesis the creation of the
world and the fall of Man right that's
the V that's that's the that's the Old
Testament readings for Christmas Eve
um if uh and this is where sort of uh
there there is some kind of different
Origins and really they're probably all
true to a certain extent but one of the
main origins of the Christmas tree comes
from the paradise tree which would be
set up on Christmas Eve which is
actually the day you're supposed to put
up your Christmas tree um not the day
after American Thanksgiving everybody um
um we sort of compromise and usually do
it on St Nicholas Day but um in my
family but uh which is in a couple of
days uh from when we're recording this
but um but anyway but but Christmas Eve
traditional day when the tree goes up
and uh and and because the idea is it's
the tree of paradise it's the Tree of
Life the tree of paradise and it was
part there's a paradise Tree tradition
both in east and west you said on well
the paradise tree not so much but I I
what I'm saying is the focus that that's
really a Western European thing but the
I'm just saying the focus on
um the focus on Adam and Eve on
Christmas Eve is a is the thing in both
the East and the west and it's something
that it's weird we kept the paradise
tree right U and actually became totally
ubiquitous in the western celebration of
Christmas and in the East too everyone
does Christmas trees now this is great
I'm super pro Christmas tree so like go
cut down a fur tree put it in your
living room um great God will be pleased
like do it but but
um but uh but it's it's interesting
because the the lurgical focus as far as
I know and I could be wrong about this
but the lurgical focus in the West on on
Genesis um on Christmas Eve has kind of
been lost but it was really cool in the
middle a they would have um uh passion
plays about Adam and Eve and this is the
main this is the main let me put it this
way this is the main time of fear when
somebody in like medieval England would
have interacted with the Genesis story
not just like not just like seen a
picture of it or like heard it read or
something like that but the main time of
year that they would have actually
interacted with it in an embodied way
would have been on Christmas Eve so they
would have they would have like play
yeah a and a passion play for people
don't know is like a paraliturgical
thing it's not something happens in the
church but it's it's it's the origin by
the way of like the like the Easter
pageant or the Christmas Pageant that
maybe you did I did lots of these
growing up as uh you know as an
Evangelical yeah and they were really
cool memories um um but but that has its
basis in the Passion Play but the
Passion Play was something that it's not
something that they did in the church
it's something that they did in like the
Village Square yeah um and they had they
had them for obviously the name Passion
Play uh uh uh you know implies passion
TI but they had them for but they had
them for all the various feces of the
year in fact the passion plays for the
for candle Groundhog Day we we talked
about that last year um were really
really cool um they had you know like a
woman from the village that they
selected to play the Virgin Mary and she
would be carrying a baby and the whole
city would Village would possess with
her up to the door of the church and
she'd present the baby to the priest and
all this stuff like it was you know and
so again these are sort of like
paraliturgical ways to uh participate in
the peast
um okay so um and then also just one
thing to mention is that because
Christmas is a day to go to church first
and foremost is all these other things
but the thing that makes it a holy day
is the fact that you're having the mass
that's the mass in in Christ Mass right
um U so it was considered to be a very
important day there were a lot of famous
Kings uh and Emperors including
Charlamagne who were ordained on
Christmas day yeah right it was just
considered to be like the most
appropriate day for this this kind of
action I said ordan uh uh uh you see
coronation ordination right but but
coronation is that is a a holy order
that's a sacrament of the church so um
all right so let me talk a little bit
real quick about Christmas in the early
modern period so what's really
interesting is that the Reformation
period gives birth to both Christmas as
we basically as we celebrate it now in
the Western Hemisphere but also to the
general anti-christmas movement right so
like both of those things come out of
the Reformation so on the one hand you
have for instance
Lutheranism Martin Luther big fan of
Christmas um and uh which I take as a
redeeming quality um and he he sort of
engineered the massive production of
Christmas hymns and carols and you can
always tell a Lutheran Carol from a
medieval Christian a medieval English
Carol because the medi medieval English
carols are like really weird and have
like a lot of of symbolism and things
like this and the Lutheran carols
because they written as theologically
explicit songs are are like very like
obviously theologically explicit and so
it's um whereas whereas like the the
older medieval carols are kind of more
riddling in nature um but this is when
Christmas trees really become a big
thing um probably related to that
paradise tree like we talked about um
and and also just the general very
ancient practice in that part of the
world of bringing Greenery into the
house as part of the winter celebration
are there are there any of the medieval
hymns that are still active
now yes um there are I I've actually
kind of put together a playlist of some
of them um of course all the ones that
we uh so are you asking about him or
carols because again that's a Carol like
christas Carol yeah um yes there are a
few um probably the oldest one that
people know well is good King Wes loss
right uh which is about the uh which is
about the practice by the way feeding
the poor at Christmas right right um and
one of my favorite songs actually but
there's
which is weird because it's not like
yeah it's like it doesn't talk about
Christmas right directly in the way that
like holy night does let's say yes yeah
well it's on the Feast of Steven which
people used to know is the second day of
Christmas but um yeah yeah people used
to know that uh better but uh but it's a
very old Carol um uh I met as as far as
other ones that are like still in
popular vernacular um
uh um I have a bunch of ones that I like
a whole lot that are not necessarily
wellknown anymore um let me think about
this maybe I'll try to post some on the
Facebook group um I put together a kind
of like a pre-modern Advent playlist and
just try to find like all the carols and
hymns that I could find that had been
written before a certain date and I I've
got about 30 or 40 things on that list
and so maybe I'll maybe I'll share that
with with everybody again but um um some
of them are like well known some of them
are you know obviously all the all the
Orthodox hyms for the feast are all you
know written in like the 8th Century so
you know that's all
squarely premodern but um but those
aren't carols right um okay so
Lutheranism produces just a massive
amount number of Christmas hymns and
carols um Christmas trees really become
a big thing um actually uh Luther was
big on Christmas trees not so much on
the crash right the nativity scene um
and uh so what really funny is
eventually this is the thing about
Christmas uh the stickiness that we've
been talking about um people don't get
rid of Christmas traditions they just
add new ones and so so some people were
like no you should do a tree not a cre
and so everybody's like great we'll do
both in fact we'll do a CR under the
Christmas tree see how see how you like
that you know yeah um makes so much
sense symbolically to have right right
it does hierarchy of heaven and and
angels of Lights you know and then at
the bottom you have the crish and you
put an angel or a star at the top are
the same thing which is the same thing
yeah I I I love this is why I love
Christmas so much and I think it was
like my one of my primary uh early like
symbolic
um my early symbolic education really
was just paying attention to Christmas
uh customs and things like I was talking
about earlier because everything about
Christmas is so deeply symbolically
intuitive um it's just really beautiful
um so and a lot of the trappings that we
think of as kind of defining the
American Christmas now were basically
brought to North America by the
moravians uh uh by the Pennsylvania
Dutch and by these these other groups
and so there were several Continental
reformed churches such as the Dutch
reformed which did continue to celebrate
Christmas um uh they celebrated as one
of the five Evangelical feasts um which
were Christmas Good Friday Easter
Ascension and Pentecost and I I I have
never understood maybe somebody out
there wants to enlighten me uh Pastor
Paul or somebody else uh why those are
the Evangelical feasts and not any of
the other things in the gospels that are
also Christian feasts like uh you know
the the name Evangelical usually when we
say something is evangelical in
historical sense we mean it's mentioned
in the gospels right but so is
Transfiguration anunciation Etc so I
don't know why are the five feasts uh
well the five Evangelical Feast at least
back then for the Dutch reformed uh
where I'm not saying of anything about
curent practice but where Christmas Good
Friday Easter Ascension and Pentecost I
think it's because Easter Ascension and
Pentecost right that's all kind of one
cluster there a coherence you know how
many days you can get it from scripture
pretty much yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that might be what it is I think it is
because the other dates you you can't
get from scripture when to to celebrate
the other ones and and this is basically
where we get the uh the general idea um
in American
Christianity um and here I'm going to
speak very broadly of kind of like the
the Christmas and Easter Rhythm if if
you know what I'm talking about like
this idea by which you have Christmas
and that's a big deal and you have
Easter which is usually a really big
deal and then but there's really nothing
else of particular spiritual
significance between the Tu other than
of course your you're just your Sunday
observance your Lord's Day observance
right that's and which is how I grew up
right
um where we really get into trouble
though Christmas wise is when we get
into the Puritans right and so here I
have to say some things um that uh well
they're I'm I'm just going to read what
they said like it's not fun uh these
were not fun people I don't know howse
to say it um ptin were not fun people
not fun people quote me on that but I
think they would have said they were not
fun people so I think it's okay um so
the the the puritanical movement and by
by this I mean English Puritans being a
sect of of English Christians who
um uh thought that the Church of England
the Reformation had not gone far enough
in rejecting what they call popery or
papism right and so so they were really
trying to like purify so you had your
Puritans who were like trying to purify
the Church of England and the
separatists who were like we're out of
here right but they really kind of the
same movement yeah um and then and then
of course uh uh my own ancestors on one
side of my family the Scottish
Calvinists um and who also did not like
Christmas oh really yeah well some of
them so so uh John Knox famously said uh
uh uh uh supported the Banning of
Christmas on the grounds that it was
superstitious um various Puritan writers
refer to Christmas as being
the trappings of poery the rags of the
Beast and so on the rags Rags of the
Beast yeah so so this is this is
actually a really important thing to
think about I think because sometimes
when people talk about this they'll say
something like well the Puritans didn't
ban Christmas actually they did for a
very short period of time um from the uh
for about 13 years it was actually
illegal to celebrate Christmas like
straight up illegal to celebrate
Christmas in England um Talk about that
in a second but they'll say something
like well they were they were rejecting
it this is what people will say they'll
say they were rejecting it because of
the over celebration and the tendency
for people to over celebrate so the
thing that I kind of want to point out
here is two things one is is there's
always been people you know ining
against don't over celebrate but it but
but it had never been necessary to ban
the holiday outright right the other
thing though is to point out
that the the act of celebration for the
p the act of Celebration
itself was associated with Superstition
and specifically Roman Catholicism yeah
right and this even has weird
manifestations um uh one of my areas of
of study that I did like a whole project
on uh in my graduate degree was actually
um the American prohibition movement uh
and the temperance movement which I'm
just really interested in for a lot of
reasons but one of the interesting
things that you'll fine if you go back
and you read a lot of the early
Temperance literature um and I have I've
actually gone to the the country's
largest Temperance archives um to like
read through a bunch of the early
literature um what you what you'll find
is that is that there is a lot of of
frankly anti-catholic sentiment as a
part of the literature of the early
temperance movement because it's the
it's the German Italian Irish immigrants
coming over here they drink who drink
and that's causing the problem actually
it was actually probably the saloons
that were causing the problem not the
beer but that's a different conversation
we can talk sometime about the symbolism
of going from we all get together as a
family to have some beer and we're
sitting at a table looking at each other
to I'm sitting at a bar facing a
bartender there's a important important
shift that happens there as part of the
Industrial Revolution but anyway
different conversation for a different
day um but the thing I want to I want to
really emphasize though is that all of
the stuff like the celebration the
drunkenness but then also like the mass
and the Liturgy right the high things
and the low things about the feast day
for the Puritan that was all a package
and it had to all be rejected um and so
this leads to the outright Banning um
starting in 1645 and then again in
1647 um there they passed an ordinance
in England abolishing the Feast of
Christmas Easter and witson or Pentecost
e too really abolishing Easter as well
like which uh which people always forget
about that wow always forget about that
and that that remains in force until the
Restoration in 1660 um in fact there was
a really fun kind of a popular song I
Wish I remember to to put the lyrics in
my notes for this talk but um there was
like a kind of a fun popular song uh
celebrating because now we know you know
that Charles has you Charles has come
back Charles II because now we know when
Christmas is yeah yeah and so there been
because there've been like a lot of
underground celebrations and things like
that going you imagine like think about
it today if we said I mean they did it
during Co some right right right they're
like you can't celebrate Christmas this
year and it's was like yeah what yeah
yeah so
um uh so yeah this is like this this was
all a package deal the Puritans believe
that by puring the Liturgy and the
iconography of the papal religion they
would also be able to usher in an era of
moral Improvement right and that's the
kind of the thing that's a a continuous
theme of of people who want to get rid
of Christmas is that by doing so we'll
make we'll become morally better as a
Society MH right that it's that
Christmas is is associated with excess
or It's associated with corruption like
decadence of some sort um which is funny
because like it's just interesting
because that's the danger of the feast
you know it's like right you think
people don't get drunk at weddings right
do you think people don't get drunk at
funerals do you think people don't you
know it's like when you gather together
to celebrate something it has uh there's
a kind of ecstasy there there's
something going on which is both very
positive but also dangerous and so you
kind of have to navigate that line so
that it doesn't fall into and it also is
a revealer it reveals it you know the
feast can reveal the nature of a group
yeah you and reveal its quality you know
because if it gets out of hand then it
it also is showing something about the
nature of that
communion yes that is that is a really
important note um
uh the other the other thing is that
when you when you try really hard to
repress this yeah right that that it
will pop up again but it'll pop up in
some really dangerously excessive way
that's right right um in the same way
that you know uh the if you you can have
Christian liturgy or you can have the
occult like pick like you know like but
but there's a lurgical impulse in human
beings that they that you know everybody
has to
participate in something so this is also
like there's so many things about this
like social dancing for example oh great
example of that where it's like it's
like can you be at a at a feast where
you dance with someone else's wife can
you is that possible and then what can
can you
maintain the order and the right the
right ordering in that kind of that
place that could Reveal Your your
Darkness let's say yeah yeah um can I
tell you a joke yeah go for it this is a
joke that we b as a Baptist growing up
we told about ourselves so
it's um it's not intended to be cruel so
it goes like how Baptist am I uh How
Baptist are you um I'm so Baptist that
we don't play Old Maid in the front of
the house because if somebody drives
through by at 50 miles hour looks
through the window sees us playing cards
they'll assume we playing poker if we're
playing poker we're gambling if you're
gambling you're fornicating and we all
know that fornication leads to
premarital dancing
that's yeah anyway just yeah this a joke
that we kind of told about ourselves but
uh but I think there's really something
to that social dancing is which is
something I was not allowed to do
growing up um and then I married a wife
my my wife who who loves dancing and uh
so we you know so she sort of like
introduced me to it and it was just like
um man it was it was a weird moment the
first time that I danced to music it was
bizarre and the reason it was bizarre I
discovered two things one is I really
like in uh but the other is that I
suddenly realized what music was for
like I I I grew up I was a violinist and
I did a lot of like Irish fiddle music
like Jigs and re which are just dances
dancing but I never danced in my life
and so my wife and I we to do like um we
got really into folk dance at a period
and we did a bunch of Scottish country
dance and uh the first time I like
danced to a a a real but I was actually
doing the real suddenly everything about
the music clicked in the place for me M
and it was just this very bizarre moment
of realizing that that like there was a
whole half of me that was dead and then
it just came to life and it was it was
just very it was very strange um so yeah
um and all this to say uh uh uh there
was this period you know a relatively
short period but a pretty Infamous
period and really scarred English
society for a long time uh where it was
actually against the law to celebrate
Christmas um and of course the real
irony in all of this is that the direct
descendants of Puritans will now fight
vociferously to have a nativity scene in
a public space that's right right to uh
to to fight for the use of Merry
Christmas instead of just happy holidays
and so on um and uh and I and and it's
because there's this stickiness about
Christmas like you can do whatever you
want to but Christmas will win
eventually it will win um um and plenty
of other people have tried to get rid of
it since the time of the Puritans we
could talk about I'll talk about some
the moment but of course there's like a
modern manifestation of puritanism that
is sort of like the political correct
the PC woke culture right uh that that
that tries really hard to get rid of
Christmas or to change Christmas or to
like reimagine it in some way I mean
think about any modern TV show it's been
a thing in American network television
for decades that you have to have a
Christmas episode yeah right and so one
of the things that you'll see in more
recent TV shows is that whenever the
Christmas episode comes around they have
to do more and more to kind of like
recontextualize What Christmas Means but
they can't get away from doing the
episode right um and Christmas man
Christmas Aesthetics they are powerful
you cannot get rid of that like just
it's weird because even like even the
the even the all the efforts of all the
marketing companies to reduce it and to
remove the Christian part of it and to
stylize it and to do that is just
feeding it like you cannot get rid of of
the chrisan sh the the
Christmas like visuals the smell the the
music it just you there's no way now
like imagine trying to to get rid of
that yeah just impossible yeah uh so
actually you mentioned the smell I
wanted to make sure I didn't forget to
mention this so uh because New England
New England specifically other parts of
the US were founded were settled by
different people many of whom were like
had no trouble with Christmas at all U
but but New England was settled by
Puritans and separatists right and one
of the really interesting things there
is that uh um at some point in the
history of New England it was before the
American Revolution um uh they the there
the towns in New England would actually
hire mince sniffers they were called
mince sniffers so the job of a mint
sniffer is to walk through the village
or walk through the town on Christmas
Day and sniff the air and make sure
nobody's cooking Christmas Foods on
Christmas day man um and you could be
like really severely punished really
severely punished for celebrating
Christmas you know um at that particular
time so um and and at that time like the
whole idea of Christmas celebration
again like that's something the German
immigrants at the End of the Street
might be doing but good Puritan families
weren't participating in that um so uh
to kind of get up up to modern times the
early 19th century is really a
Renaissance for Christmas celebrations
in the anglosphere and this is for two
reasons one is the Oxford movement which
is basically this uh it was like a
movement within the church Church of
England to uh kind of return to like a
more
patristic uh uh basis for the tradition
um it's kind of when Anglo Catholicism
as such sort of
uh uh develops into full flower right um
and kind of right along the same time
you had uh a guy named Charles Dickens
and I know they made a movie about him
Rec a couple years ago or something
called the man who invented Christmas
which I actually did not see because I
hate seeing movies about historical
figures that I I I like or I know a lot
about because I'll just get angry
especially now it's like now right maybe
20 years ago yeah yeah yeah I just don't
I didn't know what they're going to do
but so I don't know if the movie was any
good or not but it's it's like you know
there's something about the title there
the man who invented Christmas which is
like a little cheeky uh but also also
it's not totally wrong right um uh like
I said Christmas had been pretty had
taken a pretty big hit in the 17th
century and it was being celebrated in
England again but also it was it was
still like there was just a lot of every
year like kind of like uh hand ringing
around the celebration of Christmas and
Etc so but this really between the
Oxford movement and they're trying to go
back and basically Rive revive the
medieval practices of these feasts and
then Charles Dickens coming along and
and writing A Christmas Carol um uh did
a ton to revive traditional celebration
of the holiday focused especially on the
ancient theme of charitable works at
this time which again is a very
important part of traditionally
celebrating Christmas and to this day I
mean you say what you want to say about
Americans but to this day it remains
this time of year that that we are the
most likely to give to charity even
people who don't think about or give
anything to the poor the rest of the
year on Christmas there's suddenly this
like generosity that our hearts will
open up uh you know a little bit more
than they were open before yeah it's
interesting that Dickens I it's funny
because now i' never thought about that
but I think I thought about now that
it's called The Christmas Carol and it's
a secular
T you know it's not directly Christian
it it kind of floats around the themes
like what you described about the
Christmas carols that's exactly why it's
called A Christmas Carol and um uh it's
it's it's so interesting because there
are of course references to people going
to church references to Christ
references to like the theme of the day
the the the little babe and the manger
who makes the lame walk and you know Etc
right that's all in there but you're
right it's a it's not a lurgical story
it's not just a retelling of the the the
Nativity narratives from the gospels or
something like that it's this sort of
thing that's happening around the church
right in the around the church and
specifically throughout the life of one
man um and uh it kind of creates this
really uh uh I think I I think what is
so genius about the Christmas carol I
mean we should do a whole video just on
it um is that it uh uh it we're going to
talk in a moment about the these idea of
like sort of knots in time right which
is really what a feast day is and the
Christmas carol takes that idea and runs
with it because it ties Scrooge's entire
life together over the course of one
Christmas to the next that's right right
which which becomes like a really
powerful way of thinking about our own
lives right you know where were we on
this feast day what person were we on
this feast day you know um so in the
United States uh like I said Christmas
was really seen more as more of an
ethnic holiday which meant that you
actually had whole communities that just
didn't celebrate Christmas which is kind
of Unthinkable now um until about the
the late 19th century and it really
starts to be celebrated in the late 19th
century thanks to the works of poets
like the guy whose name I'm forgetting
right now who wrote uh uh the what was
originally called a visit from St
Nicholas uh it was the night before
Christmas you know that poem and then uh
which which which really basically kicks
off the whole idea of gift giving at
Christmas in the United States yeah and
joins the the Feast of saying Nicholas
with Christmas because I was wondered
like when did that happen at some point
for us it's crushed together in the West
St Nicholas and Christmas is the same
and then you you like I had a Romanian
priest in our parish for a few years and
he was really annoyed that we gave gifts
at Christmas and was like really trying
to like make sure that we give our gifts
you know on St Nicholas Day which oh
that's so fun he didn't succeed though
like nice try it's too now it's too deep
like in our yeah yeah you can't you
can't undo it um uh and then there was
also um uh Harry beer sto who wrote
Uncle Tom's Cabin which is I guess a
little Infamous now but anyway um she
also wrote a a story I think it's called
a Christmas in New England which did a
lot to kind of popularize the
celebration of Christmas and like the
whole focus of a Christmas in New
England right is on the sort of like
immigrant Community within New England
that's celebrating the holiday and that
other people kind of get involved and
participate in it and so um yeah so uh
the 18 late 19th century is really when
Christmas takes off in the United States
and this culminates in its declaration
as a Federal holiday in
1870 um and it's important to note that
for Americans that wasn't even a holiday
great Christmas wasn't even a holiday up
to the time and it's totally Unthinkable
now but like George Washington didn't
celebrate Christmas worked on Christmas
yeah like like he didn't just work on
Christmas he fought B he attacked the
hessin who were Germans on Christmas
because they were celebrating and it was
like that's like his famous like
crossing the Delaware attacks the Hess
one of the most important victories of
the American reevolution tionary War
worked because the Americans weren't
celebrating on Christmas Day and the and
the the Hess were right so it's like
these various like very interesting kind
of history there in our early uh status
as a early time as as a nation and then
Christmas kind of developing more and
more first is this immigrant thing and
then now it's totally Universal um and
so there's a lot more that we could
probably say about the symbolism of the
holiday um I kind of run out of time
here to talk about the use of like Santa
Claus as a marketing image yeah where
Coca-Cola specifically and also I think
it's important I think because this is
an argument that people use a lot is
that in some ways you know Santa Claus
today was made up by Coca-Cola and right
I really I resist that to some extent
yeah I agree I agree you know I think
that the the character of Father
Christmas and St Nicholas were there in
the 19th century you see the characters
and then they kind of get fused into one
one one character which is our modern
Santa Claus but and then and then the
marketing companies kind of jump on that
and you know Coca-Cola did simplify the
costume let's say in terms of the White
Band and stuff right and made it and
made it let's be honest like a little
more palatable to some people right like
well less less of a bishop for right
exactly some guy with a crer and a
bishop smer like that's not gonna that's
not gonna play in P in like post yeah
exactly like post Pur Puritan America
yeah um but but nonetheless like they
stumble onto all this is why when you
talk about how Christmas is so sticky
it's like yeah you know people I did a
video on Rudolph the rednose reindeer
which is basically was made up by uh
like a what was it one of the big
department stores in the United States
and it was given out at Christmas as a
gift to people buying at the dartan
store to get people into the store but
they stumbled onto true things you know
there's something about how symbolism
happens and I think in the symbolism of
Santa Claus and the way that we think
about the sleigh and everything all of
these these are very powerful images
that that uh that even though marketing
companies came up with them or brought
them up it doesn't really matter if we
recognize in them some images that have
weight and the fact that they're
remembered means that there's there's
some actual weight in those images yeah
I'm a huge sucker for Santa Claus movies
in general um uh uh Miracle on 34th
Street is a really they two remakes two
they made it twice and both both
versions are quite good I think there
was an animated film about Santa Claus
Like Us Santa Claus is like a family
Dynasty that came out a few years later
called a few years ago rather called
Arthur Christmas and um it's a it's a
really interesting movie it is uh it
does a lot of sort of interesting things
like tries to subvert the Santa Claus
symbolism at the outset and then shows
all the problems that that causes and
then by the end things have to kind of
revert back to the traditional pattern
and I haven't seen it I should watch
that yeah it's interesting it's I would
love to know your thoughts on it it's
it's it's an interesting one but um but
yeah I I think that it's one of these
weird things because actually the Soviet
Union of course tried to also abolish
Christmas and when they did they just
replaced it with a winter holiday and
they had a they had old man winter you
know who looks who's dressed exactly
like Santa Claus right and he's the one
that brings you to the presence now you
know right you know and uh it's there's
something about this right uh all of the
attempts actually to revive or or create
competing uh Winter holidays in the
secular world around us today going back
to the French Revolution favorite one is
the do you guys um do you have like the
three kings cake is that's something
that you do yeah we do that here yeah
yeah so that's that's not that's that's
a French thing it's it's not something
that I grew up with but it's a French
thing uh in so you'll you'll you'll get
a kick out of knowing that during the
French Revolution they renamed the three
kings cake to the equality cake uh which
is which is amazing because the original
story about the three kings is that you
have like the highest thing becomes low
and then the high thing comes down and
venerates the thing that's become low
that was you know like and then it's
like no know equality cake it's all
perfectly it's all perfectly even no and
they don't put they don't put the seed I
me they don't put the seed in there they
don't I assume not because it's like hey
someone get someone special if he finds
the thing can't have that you get the
guillotine that's what you get if you
find the SE yeah anyway like in Quebec
we like in French in in in Quebec we
yeah Santa Claus we called him Father
Christmas yeah like that's how so and
that's a that's a papa Noel or something
Papa Noel yeah per Noel and that's like
a that there's this whole character that
appeared in Western Europe and in France
that had the had the hat and was very
similar to the way that we understand uh
uh Santa Claus now so it's like all
these characters get fused yeah it seems
like it's a thing that that has to
happen you know yeah um there's a lot
more we could say about this but there
are a few things that I want to point
out that are like really beautiful to me
about all of this uh that we kind of
been talking about and then I'm going to
give you what I call my midwit defense
of Christmas all right so uh the first
thing is just to say that uh kind of
against the general detractors of
Christmas right that that Christmas is
actually not our most overc
commercialized time of the year um we're
always overc commercialized Christmas is
the only time of year that we notice it
right because you know if you think
about like all the kitch and like the
the the $1 you know like the bargain
bins and stuff at Target or Walmart or
whatever like those are there all year
you know but only at Christmas do you
notice it and get irritated about it
yeah um I think it is a a really
beautiful time where the sort of the
let's say the soft iconic clasm of
American religion gives way to not just
like putting up nativity scenes with
statues of Jesus Joseph and Mary like in
your house in your yard in the Village
Square right but actually defending that
practice in the court of public opinion
which is really something to think about
yeah um and uh it's also the time of
year like I mentioned but by the Numbers
we're the most generous right it's the
one day a year that even confirm ired
heathens will show up to church so I was
a pastor and from a family of pastors
and I get that there's always something
in you that wants to complain when
somebody shows up on Christmas Day or on
Easter or PCA and you haven't seen them
in a year yeah you know it's like oh so
now you're here right but but like you
could also flip that around though and
think about the fact that there's
something so potent about this day that
even the most confirmed Heathen will
still show up to light a candle right
they'll still show up to a midnight like
they'll still come to church with their
kids like they take their kids to church
by one day a year there's something
really special something really potent
about about this day so I want to kind
of explain that I'll give you what I
call my my midwit apology or or defense
of Christmas and I call it a midwit um
uh some people know I'm a big fan of
like the the format of a midwit meme
right and so you know the the I'm sure
we can put one up here on the screen or
something but you know the idea is is
you have like a really dumb person at
one end and a really smart person at the
other end and there's bell curve in the
middle and the bell curve in the middle
that guy's the midwit um so in this case
the meme is the really the really simple
person who says celebrate Christmas
because it's Jesus birthday right and
then at the other end you have the saint
who says the same thing celebrate
Christmas because it's jesus' birthday
and for a lot of people and uh I'll I'll
go as far as to say probably the
majority of the people watching this
video that is enough that is enough but
for all the people kind of like in the
middle there the
source yes the sources people yes we
need like a little more kind of an
explanation or understanding of why
we're doing the things that we're doing
and and again as I said to me this is a
really important this really important
thing so um I'm going to read some
little bits and and kind of talk through
some bits from Charles Taylor's work a
secular age which is one of the most
important books that I think anybody
could read right now um and what's
amazing is that a lot of the ideas that
I have really benefit benefited from
here on the symbolic World listening to
your videos and conversations over the
last several years I first encountered
in Taylor and then when I saw your
videos I was like oh somebody else is
talking about that same thing right and
it was just really I don't know
validating a certain way so uh he talks
about basically this idea that there are
three kinds of time for medieval man
there are three kinds of time and the
the first one is the uh uh in in one of
our previous videos I referred to this
as the difference between Kronos and
chyros as two kinds of time but Taylor
says there's three right so there's
first of all there's there's Kronos
which we could refer to as was what what
Taylor calls homogeneous or empty time
right which for modernity is the central
form of time yeah right history as a
series of accidents right in the
philosophical sense like history has a
series of accidents cause and effect and
just sort of this cause and effect in an
endless chain with no particular meaning
to it right and then um the second kind
of time is
um uh he says he uh the second kind of
time is is what we could call chotic
time and so uh kairotic time would be
time fil being filled with meaning so
Taylor says that the time of Carnival
for instance is kairotic uh that is the
timeline encounters kairotic
knots uh so you have this the straight
line and then suddenly you hit kind of
like a knot where everything gets kind
of snarled up and bended together and um
moments whose nature and placing calls
for reversal followed by others
demanding rededication and still others
which approach parusia so this is his
shro Tuesday lent Easter right so shro
Tuesday that's Marty Gro right is this
great moment of Carnival or reversal
followed by lent for rededication and
then Easter which is like parusia the
coming the revealing so there are now
there are kairotic knots in the stories
we tell about ourselves in our time
revolutions themselves are understood by
their heirs and supporters as such
kairotic moments you think about
whatever country you live in and and the
the important political moments or like
revolutions that you've had uh in my
case like the American Revolution comes
this huge kind of kairotic moment where
the actual details and timelines about
George Washington and Benjamin Franklin
and the founding fathers in July the 4th
and all that stuff is less important
than all of those things kind of being
gathered together in that particular
moment yeah um it says National hor
historiography is full of such moments
but what has changed is that around
which these moments gather so in the
pre- watered
era um the organizing field for ordinary
time comes from these higher times so
the higher times are uh basically two
sources um so if you think of ordinary
time is like secular time uh I know that
the word secular can mean various
different things here but for now we'll
just call it this sort of homogeneous
chronological time um there are kind of
two sources for that meaning um and one
is uh what is eternity right eternity
sort of breaking into ordinary time and
then the other is what uh uh uh Taylor
calls like the great time right uh at
this is this is like say like mythical
time this is like when all the important
stuff happen to make the way the world
that it is today right um so if you're
you know living in like a pre uh like
like a stone age civilization or
something the great time is like when
the gods were on Earth walking around
among Mortals right you know um for the
Christian Story the great time is really
the gospel right the gospels when Christ
was here on Earth right when he's
establishing these things and there's
this idea that um Taylor really develops
um the way that you have the horizontal
dimension of secular time but also these
vertical Dimensions where
uh where
eternity and where or or and the and or
the great time kind of break into that
secular time and you could say like the
more pronounced that happens the bigger
the not becomes yeah and um this is what
makes uh these relationships and it's
really a three-way relationship between
homogeneous time and uh and you know
like our mythical history and then
eternity Yeah the more relationships
they are the bigger the not becomes and
this is actually what gives time meaning
and uh there's a famous line uh in
Hamlet and I'm still waiting for all the
symbolic world people to have like the
big Hamlet moment so maybe it'll happen
um um because Hamlet is a tremendously
important one of Shakespeare's most
important place it's a tremendously
important work of literature because it
it's one of the things that Hamlet is
grappling with is the is the sort of the
great uh disenchantment and the Passover
from the ancient world into the modern
right it's it's not for nothing that um
that Hamlet has just come from you know
University you know in Germany at the
birthplace of the Reformation he's just
come from University in Germany at the
birthplace of modernity right he's
coming back and he's trying to apply
these modern understandings to this
these encounters with the world that are
just wild and insane his father is a
ghost and his mother you know and and
being cuckle that like all these things
and Hamlet eventually goes insane like
trying to kind of keep it all together
um you know and you know get stabbed in
a duel and everything else as well but
but I mean the the kind of the point you
know uh this is one of the big things
the the the the play is wrestling with
and um but there's this line in there
where he says the times are out of joy
the times are out of joint which has
kind of become like a like a phrase but
this is what it means it means that uh
he's not just saying the condition of
Danish Society at this particular time
is lamentable that's not what he means
he means that things aren't fitting
together in the proper fashion anymore
as they do in times which are closer to
those ordering paradigms of Eternity and
of the Sacred time um and uh and it's
it's interesting this comes relatively
soon after his he's having a discussion
with marcelus and Marcela says you know
that ghosts and goblins don't dare walk
the earth on Christmas Eve you know on
so hallowed and so gracious is the time
by the way you know this is is Hamlet A
Christmas Story well if Die Hard is a
Christmas story Hamlet is definitely a
Christmas story but anyway um so the
thing with Christmas is that it's one of
these moments and the other moment
really is the the crucifixion uh which
is something that that uh that Taylor
also
identifies that uh the crucifixion and
and Christmas are these two moments
where there's a complete like like the
relationships that kind of keep all of
these things related to each other are
like the most complete right the
symbolism matches up the most right you
could say and uh because of that these
moments become extremely sticky or the
knots become like really really Tangled
and and it becomes almost impossible
becomes almost impossible to disentangle
those things and so what people try to
do is sort of cut the gordian KN and
just like cut right through it and say
no more Christmas right but but it but
it Christmas has this tremendous
regenerative quality to it um and I
think it's because it's the moment when
it's the moment when the Great Time and
Eternity and chronological time I mean
it's really important that Christ was
born in Bethlehem we know more or less
the day we know more or less the year
but it's really important that that God
enters history uh because the other
option is that you have with the
situation that the Greeks had which
would be chronological time and then uh
eternity like the world of ideas and but
there's nothing there's nothing to kind
of bridge the gap between them so what
they end up coming up with is the idea
of time is being sort of SE Eternal
which is constantly constantly
progressing like no basically time with
no beginning or no end right uh like
always change but never fulfillment
right but in Christmas we get this we
get this this fulfillment of all of
these things and and all of the sort of
the ver vertical and the horizontal
dimensions of time come together in this
warp yeah yeah which is appears in the
story itself like we mention obviously
we don't want to go through all the
Christmas symbolism but yeah there it is
the the tree with the with the with
nativity set you know at the at the
bottom the manger whether it is the
angels singing down to the Shepherds you
know there are they're just countless or
it is these these wise men that come
from afar like all of the symbolis of
Christmas is about this intersection in
the story itself
not even accounting for what it is what
it's actually doing for us at that
moment and so this is my just to wrap
this up this is my argument for why you
have to celebrate Christmas right it's
not
just
enough to
believe that the the child born of a
virgin was the logos from before the
ages right we can say we believe that or
we want to but if we don't act on that
information some way and the way that
you act on this information the the the
uh Taylor refer talks about liturgy and
like the the let's say he talks about
the feast the act of Celebration as
being like a song right so the song has
a a Melody like a think of like a little
Melody has sequential moments you know
all these different notes and everything
but but really the beginning to the end
of that song all happen in the same
moment because it's a unit right so if
you don't sing the song then you're not
actually you have no way of
participating in it in that moment the
moment just passes You by right and if
you don't celebrate Christmas then the
moment this holy moment right this
moment when Heaven and Earth everything
comes together into this point right
that moment just passes You by and
pretty soon you stop believing at all
right you stop really thinking I mean uh
there uh you know there's there are
certain organizations that will do like
polls to see like what's the state of
belief you know and like year after year
um if you look at this uh one of the
questions on there is um is uh uh true
or false Jesus Christ is the greatest
being ever created by God right and so
um and that's that's one of the
questions on the survey and horrible
question every well yeah it's it's
definitely a leading question right but
freaky question man yeah but what
happens is that every year or every four
years when they do the survey that
number goes up by 10 or 15% yeah right
where people are just sort of like
sliding into
aryanism right and um you know there's a
lot that could be said about the state
of catechesis and Theological education
in churches in America day etc etc but
really the thing that we need to do is
not just put Christ back in Christmas
but put the mass back in Christmas right
to really keep the feast to keep the
celebration and you can keep it at every
single one of these Dimensions you can
go to church and contemplate the mystery
you can wake your neighbors up uh you
know at 9:00 at night and seeing seeing
them songs and offer them booze like you
can do all of this stuff right you can
participate in all of these dimensions
and if you do you'll be more of a human
being than you were but if you do you
will also be able to draw closer to
Christ and closer to your neighbor right
and that actually without these things
what ends up happening is that time just
becomes does every does anybody remember
covid right with all the celebrations
taken away like like what happened time
happened during Co exactly time just
becomes this long kind of like like
undifferentiated linear yeah you know
passage and and nothing there and
there's no memory right there's no
memory there's no participation so
that's the midwit explanation the easy
one is it's Jesus birthday why wouldn't
you celebrate it
so all right Richard that's great thank
you so much and uh don't forget
Everybody by the way that Richard will
be there at the symbolic World Summit so
if you I have so many crazy things
planned for the universal history panel
I mean I'm really gonna I'm going to
really like just not restrain myself
even a little bit we're going to get
into some really fun weird stuff so so I
can't I definitely can't wait to
everybody thanks again Richard I wish
you a Merry Christmas and uh likewise
see you in the in the in the new year I
want to invite you all to the very first
symbolic World Summit over 3 days we
will finally meet in real time in real
space and everyone from this little
corner of the internet will be there to
explore the theme of reclaiming the
cosmic image of course will be speaking
but there will also be Martin Shaw who
is an amazing mythographer father Steven
D young of Lord of spirit Fame there
will be Richard Roland from the
universal history series Vesper Stamper
Nicholas kotar and Neil de gr that
you've all seen on my channel here and
there for entertainment we have
everyone's favorite apocalyptic band The
One and Only dirt po Robins this event
will be the chance of a lifetime to
capture and embrace our current moment
so join us from Fe ruary 29th to March
2nd 2024 in Tarpon spings Florida visit
the symbolic
world.com Summit for more information
and I will see you
there